um something that
i just was in discussion with with like
friends and family during this
um
last election or
electing voting people into the office
and all that good stuff
was how can
someone
make a law for
um like low-income people when they
don't understand what it is to be in
that situation
and it's kind of like if you
if you don't know the situation you can
empathize with someone but you're not
going to physically understand what it
is to be
in
a certain situation whatever it is
and so that was just like
part of the conversation i had and it's
hard to be able
to
be like okay yeah i understand when you
may
you may emotionally understand what it
is to be in like a harsh situation but
mentally and physically
if you've never been in it you're never
going to
fully understand it
this was there a law you were talking
about i cannot remember off the top of
my head it was it was just like amidst
um
election time and
it was talking about the people that we
were electing i
can't remember okay i was just wondering
if it was like a specific law if i
remember that i'll be like yeah it was
this right now my brain's like
i see all right which brings us to the
unconstrained vision
when again i'm quoting you when rousseau
said that man is born free but
everywhere in chains
he expressed the essence of the
unconstrained vision which the in which
the fundamental problem is not nature or
man but institutions yes would you
explain that one well he has the notion
that uh again that that good things
happen naturally
uh if there are bad things it's because
uh institutions including civilization
itself have have made these bad things
happen
and of course uh so it's kind of like
like again back to the credit example
like oh it's society
so in that example like the
like the way he's talking like it's like
society is making us do these spending
habits and i would save if it wasn't for
society okay does that make sense
yes and i think that that's really the
the implicit assumption behind a lot of
things that are said on the left today
uh and
why in my most recent book i go to a lot
of trouble to show that
in nature
there's nothing resembling equal
opportunity that wherever you look
around the country around around the
world
you find people who live up in the
mountains poor and backwards even in the
richest countries
including the united states
i believe the poorest country in the
united states the county rather
was in a mountain community
which was almost 100 percent white
somewhere in appalachia west virginia
yeah southern ohio right yes
uh
and the men in that in that county
had a life expectancy 10 years less
than men in a county in
virginia
and the constrained the unconstrained
vision says let's fix that we surely we
can pass a law that would improve that
and the constrained vision says well now
wait a moment
if people who live in isolated pockets
and mountains are poor and backwards all
around the world and we see this pattern
over and over and over again
maybe there's something very deeply
rooted in reality about that
that's hard for us to get at correct yes
all right
so in the book a conflict of visions
you're very dispassionate and very
analytical
and you lay out the unconstrained vision
and you lay out the constrained vision
and you don't really come out blazing
in favor of one or the other no
yeah that is not a book meant to commit
to
a show one vision is better than the
other it's there to show you what what
they are and what you're assuming if you
if you go one direction or another okay
and it's to encourage people to
understand the implicit assumptions
behind all this without which you you're
just a lot at luke
would you say that the government um in
the states is more
constrained or unconstrained
i think it depends on the state
i think texas is more unconstrained i
think california is more constrained
okay
i can see it yeah
it's
it's so like hard because you
you want to be able to like
depend on the government to
help out everybody but in the grand
scheme of things
it's just not going to happen i think
the problem is there's unintended
consequences like they say the path to
hell is paved with good intentions so
i'll give you an example in california
um in california they wanted to help the
homeless population
so they gave out
they're giving money to homeless people
people that are homeless and that
resulted in people moving to california
to be homeless
wow yeah and there's a guy on the um
that they recorded he was like being
interviewed and he literally tells them
he's like i'm a crackhead i moved from
texas to california so i could be
homeless because they pay you to be
homeless here it's great i get 600 bucks
a month to just yeah
right now
i know
i'm about to be
but you see like so so again it's these
people saying oh i know what's best so i
know what's best for these people that
i'm not mm-hmm and i'm i'm gonna pat
myself on the back oh look at me i'm
helping the poor
wow unintended intentionally hurting
people that actually are functioning
members of society because now they have
to deal with all these homeless people
that
that is
that makes a lot of sense first of all
first of all six hundred dollars a month
for be homeless
it's
it sucks
to know that that's the thing because i
literally pack up everything like i'm
homeless like yo give me my 600 a month
thank you um
but they say that
the homeless in california are more
privileged than
any other like homeless population
anywhere else because they are in
california and it's mind-blowing like
you can be a privileged
homeless person
well and it's it's funny because maybe
it seems mean to say no you can't be on
the street but
it's it's not because it makes them
figure something else out it's just and
some people don't like now
if someone's homeless
and
they wanted to
get on get on their feet now they can be
like well
i don't have to have responsibilities
don't have to work and i'm getting 600 a
month i'll just stay homeless like in
california
they have
areas where they have built
houses
tenth houses and they'll have tvs
they'll have cabinets they'll have
everything just on the sidewalk chilling
like it's an outdoor home i remember i
told my mom that she said that's not
fair they can be out there they got to
pay rent that's not fair that they can
live out there on their own and just
take up the sidewalks space like no
they're gonna have to pay something to
be able to do that and i was like at
first i was like no like they're
homeless they can't do that what are
they gonna do and now i'm like oh yeah
you all live here
and make things higher i'm sorry and
you're getting six hundred
you better
chip in somewhere because everything's
hiking up and you know who they take it
from you yeah because it comes out of
your taxes